jumpin shark sightings closed along the
southern california coast has lifeguards
on high alert a great white shark was
spotted Wednesday just feet away from a
paddle boarder in Long Beach nearly 30
sharks were spotted from Long Beach to
San Onofre beach in just one day this
week
yikes Carter Evans is in Long Beach
right now with the threat to swimmers
and the surfers Carter good morning and
be careful good morning I'm on dry land
out of these signs are fair warning
enter at your own risk the experts say
all these sightings are part of a larger
trend there do appear to be more great
white sharks in the water so we went up
with the Orange County Sheriff's
Department and take a look this year has
been the largest number influx of the
great white sharks that I've seen along
the coast and the my 24 years just
minutes into our helicopter flight we
spotted three great whites swimming in
shallow water less than 50 feet from the
shoreline this just one day after a
group of sharks for sheriff's deputies
to clear the water attention in the
water this is the Orange County
Sheriff's Department so you have paddle
boarding next to approximately 15 great
white sharks deputy Brian stunk Bridge
made that announcement exit the water in
a calm manner what was the response of
the people in the water well unlike
normal they pretty much complied
immediately many of the sharks appear to
be juvenile great whites six to eight
feet long in about a year old there have
been an unusual number of sightings this
year shark populations are increasing
marine biologist Chris Lowe runs the
shark lab at Cal State Long Beach the
reason why I think we're seeing more
sharks is because we protected them
they've been protected in US waters
since 2005 the other thing is there's
lots of food so along our beaches the
stingray populations have been exploding
of last 50 years would you go swimming
here
I'm not going to go swimming here this
summer even though shark sightings have
become more common attacks are still
rare a San Diego County mother was
critically injured last month after
witnesses say a shark bit off part of
her leg at a popular surf spot but lo
says sharks are not interested in eating
humans instead the young babies are
hugging the coastline to hunt for food
in a safe place but we haven't seen
signs of those young sharks actually
being a potential threat to humans when
their babies are afraid of pretty much
everything so they may not be that
different from us
now these shark sightings are actually
becoming so common that some businesses
are looking to cash in for the first
time this weekend Nora there is a new
shark boat tour well there you go
alright Carter thank you